monsieur legault qui a surpris madame
plan nous raconter ça en début
d'émission qui a surpris la mairesse de
montréal andy à bombay que la ville de
montréal présente un nouveau projet du
train de l'est si celui ci ne fonctionne
pas faut comprendre que on est on parle
du rêve ça c'est la 1er 1er m là qui est
en cours
repp de l'ess
2029 en principe dix milliards de
dollars c'est un énorme projet qui parle
de pointe aux trembles et qui va et
c'est un détail important parce que vous
allez voir dans une discussion qu'on va
voir et qui va suivre en parallèle le
train la ligne verte du métro de
montréal certains disent pourquoi on
arrête pas là parce qu'on n'a pas besoin
de fragiliser le métro de montréal en
mettant un trait je trouve sans trouver
la caisse de dépôt et placement est le
maître d'oeuvre non non non on a besoin
de moyens de transport on a besoin de
passagers qui vont se rendre jusqu'au
centre-ville
la rtm qui l agence métropolitaine qui
gère en principe les projets de
transports a donné un rapport au
gouvernement du québec jeudi dernière
disent ah si mal ficelé ça va fragiliser
le métro il faut qu'ils refassent
parlant de la caisse de dépôt leur
devoir je vous rappelle donc cet immense
comme projet pour ça que le premier s'en
mêle 10 milliards
2029 32 km 23 stations avec moi deux
personnes qui connaissent très bien le
sujet anie samson experts mais reste
pardon de l'arrondissement de villeray
saint michel parc extension et luc
ferrandez
experts vous le savez du plateau mont
royal alors est ce qu'on est en train
première question que je vous pose on
écoutera la mairesse ou thalès qu'on est
en train de vouloir tuer le projet luc
oui moi je pense que oui d'abord je
pense qu'il ya eu une surprise générale
quand on a appris que les caténaires
était si imposant sur la structure et
donc ce n'est pas juste la structure
comme on nous l'avait montré jusqu'à
présent une structure de béton assez
légère keira préval à centrer vers une
structure avec des poteaux qui défilent
et beaucoup de fils comme on est en
hiver ça prend beaucoup de puissance
pour ses wagons lada pour sécuriser et
donc des gros cri les docks de file dont
peu de premières choses la deuxième
chose qu'on a appris que c'était
possible de rentrer à espérer et lol ça
commence à s'accumuler hélas la rtm et
avec la troisième nouvelle qui était la
cane cane habile de cannibalisation de
la ligne verte par le rêve et là ça
commence à faire trop et comment sortir
d'un projet comme celui là je pense que
c'était la façon de faire c'est de dire
j'ai un rapport qui me dit ça marche pas
je remet ça sur les épaules de madame
plantes c'est à elle de décider ali on
viendra en détail sur tous les aspects
que le souligner mais un niveau vous
connaissez bien les à montréal vous
militez pour ce projet là où j'avais est
ce que vous voyez aussi qu'on est en
train d'être de l'enterrer là bas on est
à la limite la ligne les films entre la
réussite ou l'échec et les questions on
doit vraiment se poser c'est pourquoi on
a demandé c'est là la rtm qui quelques
années a déjà déposé un projet en disant
il faut qu'on en plus de transport on en
a besoin pour développer l'ess voici et
aujourd'hui on nous dit ben finalement
c'est peut-être pas bon l'on nous dit
que comme la ligne les proches la ligne
verte et le corps avec avec leur m ça va
enlever les gens qui vont y aller mais
dans leur rapport ils disaient qu'en 20
26 dans ligne verte était pour être
débordées et c'était une des raisons
pour lesquelles on avait besoin d'avoir
de nouveaux moyens de transport et de
l'autre côté oui on parle de transport
mais leur mc plus que tu transports
c'est le développement de l'est de
montréal si le développement de terrain
développement d'habitations n'arrête pas
de dire qu'on a pas d'endroit où
construire il ya 27 millions de pieds
carrés sur le bord du fleuve à
développer il ya 100 millions du
gouvernement fait provincial pour
décontaminer les terrains il ya là un
terrain de jeu incroyable pour recoller
mais pour développer effectivement
si on peut mettre plein écran la carte
parce que je veux donner un détail ceux
qui disent dont la rtm que ça va
fragiliser le métro c'est que voyez
honoré beaugrand à ses petits ont pu
prendre l'autre carte qui est zoom et
s'il vous plaît voilà on aurait beau
gras
avant il y avait une
jonction entre le nouveau train de l'est
et honoré-beaugrand de sorte que les
gens pouvaient prendre le métro après
avoir plus quelques stations du train de
l'est là il n'ya plus vous pourrez
descendre des marches et donc est ce que
la caisse qui décèdent tous ça
ne travaille pas encore une fois en vase
clos sans discuter derrière la mairesse
de montréal a demandé tout à l'heure
plus tôt dans l'émission l'udc d'avoir
une place autour de la table avec la
caisse pour parler de ces choses-là puis
ils ont dit non apparemment
oui d'abord ils ont dit non à la
mairesse ensuite ils ont dit non à
bureaux d'un conjoint un bureau de
travail conjoint dur ou de projets
conjoints ensuite ils ont dit non à une
gestion du matériel roulant conjointe
ils ont dit non à tout quand la caq se
présente dans une réunion de la ville
pour déposer pour discuter c'est sur la
base de ces plans elle dépose développe
et dit voici ici j'aurais besoin que
vous détournez ce boulevard est si
j'aurai besoin que vous enleviez dégoût
c'est tout c'est comme ça les réunions
ya pas travail qu'ont joué avec la ville
de montréal et c'est dommage ou dit et
c'est ce qui va peut être faire que ça
va pas avancer mais si le modèle ses
modèles que la laque à quoi s'était pas
par
égoïsme et chan citée fermeture c'est
que la claquette a dit écoutez on n'est
jamais agréable à faire à projets
transports en commun à montréal nous on
va vous en faire un à quatre vous allez
voir on va connecter l'aéroport on va
faire 36 km et c'est pour ça on a besoin
d'une noix qui nous permet de faire ce
qu'on veut d'aller la visiter à ce qu'on
veut et on va avancer mais ça n'a pas
marché ça peut marcher parce qu'ils y
ont quand même rencontré des écueils
important et est donc comme ce projet-là
de fast track n'a pas fonctionné vais
peut-être qu'on est mieux de revenir à
un projet d'intégration avec le métro de
montréal en collaboration que la rtm est
restée à ce que vous partagez le même
constat que le fast track pour reprendre
les mots de lui pour ce projet qu'on
voit là dans son entièreté que les
possibilités que ça marche vraiment sur
sont pas très fortes pourquoi pas
réinventer un projet peut-être plus
modestes mais la caisse de dépôt ont
reçu un mandat justement de la part du
gouvernement mme à la demande de la rtm
qui son rôle est de planifier les
développements et c'est la rtm qu'elle
fait un rapport en disant nous avons
besoin d'avoir plus de transport pour
pour que les gens puissent en profiter
il ya un manque d espace la ligne rouge
à la lune orange est complètement
débordé la verte dans quelques années et
c'est ça la base de sa queue leu leu
cdpq un froid a dit ok parfait vous nous
mandaté de faire un projet voici on
dépose un projet low aujourd'hui parce
que le projet avance trop vite faut se
rappeler en rappelez vous une dernière
fois la faisait quand un gros projet
montréal on n'a pas en avance car on
arrive près de la réalisation l'on met
les pieds sur le frein on n'atteint pas
mon à part on le fait avec le avec la
langue bleue qu'on attend toujours
depuis plus de 35 ans maintenant on
était prêts de le faire puis hop ska
qu'on était en vie pour le faire à un
nouvelle technologie on a changé d'idée
au repos or brasse toujours nos cartes
ce qu'il faut se rappeler il sait qu'on
est une grande métropole on a la chance
le la conjugue de la conjoncture elle
est là pour qu'on puisse construire
quelque chose de grand de magnifiques
qui va développer cette villa qui va
développer une partie de la ville 10
milliards de dollars bon le problème
qu'on va avoir le le problème qu'on
risque d'avoir c'est de le perdre
complètement et depuis c'est c'est un
des quatre projets mondial qui se fait
en transport en fait partie des quatre
plus gros projet en drainant projet
c'est pas rien le cpo juste hontas une
couleur pour autant cela ligne c'est un
projet de développement catalysateur
c'est tout le
plein de choses il ya des détails à
régler est-ce que la skull parce que ça
fait couler beaucoup d'encre je parle
même pas de la partie rené lévesque
surélevé se sait pas encore réglé c'est
toujours le même projet vers la fin
centre-ville on verra il y aura un
rapport bientôt mais on s'est aperçu lui
qui a ni que esthétiquement au y avait
beaucoup de fils l'on n'est pas sur les
maquettes au début on voyait pas autant
de frissons peut voir les images des
caténaires
il va avoir du fil pas peu près alors
parce que c'est électrique évidemment
est ce que ça vous dites le que sap est
un facteur qui a fait réfléchir le
gouvernement voyant que peut-être les
gens est moins enthousiaste pourquoi oui
oui le gouvernement offre a réagi
lorsque les bus ça ils n'étaient pas
plus au courant que nous le gouvernement
lula sur le vélo il ya surprise de voir
combien c'était épouse mais c'est pas la
seule chose
le travail de ya premièrement ça c'est
une des choses la deuxième chose pour
parier sur l'esthétisme et après ça
j'aimerais première ce retour sur
l'esthétisme il faut qu'un quand le
quand le real va rentrer en souterrain à
peu près à la hauteur de l'a vu plus par
de très haut puis il faut qu'il rentre
sous terre et un rsa peut pas faire
c'est pas les montagnes russes et ça
descend très très doucement une pente de
2% à peu près ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'à descendre s'amorce à papineau et
donc avec avait donc on est cette grosse
structure qui va descendre d'abord très
haute ensuite au niveau nos yeux ensuite
au niveau du sol ensuite vinrent
apprécié terre sur une très longue
on n'a pas vu d'objections
ceux qui défendent le projet annie en a
quand même qui les attend donc attendons
de voir les plans finaux avant de tirer
sur le projet non oui actuellement il ya
un comité qui travaille ensemble comme
telle qu'on attendait rapport
prochainement mais pour faire un projet
comme c'est habituellement le ce comité
l'eau doit travailler à peu près deux
ans pour arriver à un projet à la fin
qui va avoir rallié tous au donc je
dirais que c'est comme encore du travail
qui se fait y'a rien de finalisé on est
là ça veut dire que le ya des hausses
mais on va regarder comment on est
capable tranquillement enlever les
listes qu'il faut puis comment modifier
les choses on est dans la première année
de cette qualité là haut quand même
donné la chance le régent d'un projet
mme reding rapidement j'aimerais dire
c'est pas l'aspect esthétique que tu es
le projet en bout de ligne c'est
l'esprit l'aspect financier économique
et ça ça peut être travaillée moi je
pense que le rôle de madame plantes
maintenance et d'exiger un projet pour
l'est de montréal pas un abandon du
projet mais exiger quand même une fois
j'ai par exemple branchies sera honoré
beaugrand parce que les réticences de la
caisse sont pas si énorme que ça est ce
que c'est possible d'avoir un projet qui
dessert tout l'est il va chercher des
avantages durables mais qui se branchera
doré bulls
on va peut-être sur par les pirates
toujours rien produit
à nice tension luc ferrandez merci nous
avons parlé d'un gros gros projet en
raison de souligner parmi les quatre
cinq plus gros sur la planète
actuellement merci merci merci